ما الذي يجعل هذه الصواريخ صرمات لا مثيل
لها كما يقول فلاديمير بوتين مرحبا حسنيه
بالفعل هذا الصاروخ مرعب جدا اذا ركزنا مع
قدراته العسكريه وميزاته التقنيه كما ذكرت
يسمى صرمات ويفضل ايضا الخبراء التقنيون
ان يطلقون عليه بالشيطان الثاني او او ملك
الصواريخ الى حد الان ويعد واحد من سته
اهم صواريخ استراتيجيه اعلنت عليها موسكو
تحدثت عليه بعض المقالات الصحفيه عام 2017
لكن في عام 2018 كانت اولى التجارب على
صاروخ صارمات البالستي عابر للقارات هذا
الصاروخ يبلغ طوله 35 متر فاصل ثلاثه
امتار اما قطره قطره عفوا ثلاث امتار وزنه
يصل الى 200 طن وهو قادر على
هذه الكلمه قال انهم بعد رؤيه صواريخ او
صاروخ سوف يفكر الاعداء بدل مره مرات في
الحاق الاذى بروسيا لك ان تتخيلي مع كل
هذه حسنيه القدرات التقنيه الهائله كيف
يشعر الان مخاوف كبيره في العالم خاصه بعد
اعلان موسكو تعليقها العمل بمعاهده نيو
ستارت